hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it's
the 23rd of April and you are tuned into
games but news first off there's a new
racing game coming out and reportedly
it's as impressive technologically as it
is very silly a name Slightly Mad
Studios project cars is coming to xbox
one ps4 Wii U and PC and the studio are
describing it as the most authentic
beautiful and technically advanced
racing game on the planet you can make
your own judgments on that trailer
you're looking at right now which has
just been released or you can bank on
the very heavy praise being dosed on the
game from its developer who says
featuring world-class graphics and
handling a groundbreaking dynamic time
of day and weather system and deep
tuning and pit stop functionality
project cars leaves the competition
behind in the dust the first image of
this year's cool of GD game was shown of
the game developers conference last
month basically it's a guy's face but
really close up obviously sledgehammer
games are pretty keen to show off what
their in-game rendered characters look
like and this is a pretty great example
the finely detailed shot depicts
everything down to the pores on the
soldiers face and might back up
Activision's claims that this
installment will in fact be as ambitious
and creative as they're promising let me
know if you think acting are going to
surprise us this year or not next up
we're feeling for our friends in China
today as their government wants to ban
all the video games all right so it's
not all the video games but it turns out
China lifting its 14-year ban on console
games has come with a massive grain of
salt in the form of a list of unapproved
gaming content the list includes items
that will be censored such as anything
that promotes or insights obscenity drug
use violence or gambling as you'd
imagine that puts a lot of games out of
the running while developers can alter
their games and resubmit if they so
choose it's unlikely that China will
ever approve of GTA 5 all games and even
DLC must get approval by the Shanghai
government culture department under
these new rules finally today the Lords
of the Fallen dev are apparently
having a bit of a hard time getting
their game to 1080p on the Xbox one
executive producer Thomas go up has said
we're working very hard right now to
deliver ps4 and xbox one in 1080p but I
can't confirm whether it's possible it's
probably easier for me to confirm it'll
happen for ps4 because it appears on
this one and we're almost nailing it and
pretty much there for Xbox one though
it's slightly tougher and we're still
working on it Goff also said they're
hoping to hit at least 30 frames per
second since they'd like to opt for a
solid frame rate to a higher endless
stable one let me know in that
commenting section below whether you
prefer a higher frame rate or a more
stable one or if you prefer you can chat
to me on my Twitter where I'm at just
McDonald those are all the things I have
to tell you about today but tomorrow
Australia's on holidays yet again so for
the rest of the week Chris will be
taking care of you and your gaming news
requirements of the on Monday